Hello world,
it's a Raj and Monero is the currency
that I'm going to talk about today.
So first I want to start
off by saying one thing,
I do not condone any illegal
usage of any cryptocurrency.
Monero is an untraceable cryptocurrency
and definitely lots of people who like
to sell things illegally
on the internet use it.
But the reason that I'm talking
about it is not for that.
The reason I'm talking about it is
because you should be able to control your
data and some of your data
is transactional data and
currently companies can
mine that data for free and use that to
make predictions about what you will buy
and what you won't buy. So they can
show you ads and stuff like that.
But ideally they pay you for this data,
right?
And the only way for them to pay you
for that data is if you control it.
And the only way you can control it is
if it's anonymous and they have to ask
you for permission to see your
transaction history. Okay.
So monero is the currency I'm
going to talk about today.
And I have this image here of this,
these three different features that
I thought was the best high level
description of Minero.
So it says decentralized,
private and digital and Monroe
is all three of these things.
So it's decentralized
because no one controls it.
It's digital because you can run it over
the internet and it's private because
no one can tell who you are
when you send the transaction.
That means no one can tell
who sent a transaction,
who you sent it to and the amount
that you sent. So it's all private.
Unlike bitcoin and these three kind of
Venn diagram looking things are examples
of assets or currencies that are
examples of two of these, right?
So bitcoin is decentralized
cause no one controls it.
It's digital because it runs over
the Internet. Um, Fiat currency,
like a dollar is private because
you can exchange it by hand.
It's digital because you can do
it over the internet as well.
And Gold is decentralized because
no one authority controls it.
And it's private because no one can tell.
You know,
if you just take some gold
and give it to someone else,
there's no third party involved so
no one can tell anything about that
transaction.
Okay.
So Minero is all three of these things
and there are other cryptocurrencies that
are all three of these things.
But in terms of popularity and Monero
is definitely at the top right now at
least. So let's get into this
technical analysis of how Minero works.
I'm going to talk about all
the features and the narrow,
I'm going to talk about
how you can mine it.
I'm going to talk about how you can buy
it. And mostly this is a technical talk.
So we're gonna go into the technical
details of how these transactions are
private and what differences
it has from bitcoin. Okay.
So the first thing I want to talk about
is the difference between Minero in
Bitcoin.
So got this great list here of all these
different features that [inaudible] has
and all the different features
that bitcoin has and how
they're different, right?
Because they are very different.
Some of them are very similar,
like they both use the proof of work
algorithm to secure the network. Um,
they're both digital currencies. Um, they
both have a transaction fee. However,
Minero's is much less than bitcoins.
I don't know what, what is it?
Bitcoin is now like $20 a
transaction. Just crazy. It's crazy.
Block time is much faster from,
from a narrow,
but the real difference here,
the real key difference
is the trackable factor.
Monero is untraceable and it's
an linkable. Bitcoin is not, um,
I'm going to go into the details of what
I mean, like really into the details. So,
so stick around.
So a lot of the hype around
Bitcoin was that it's this, oh,
it's this pseudonymous currency.
No one can't know.
There's no third party involved.
There's no bank. You own your currency,
you own your data, you
own your assets. But the,
but the truth is that bitcoin is
very, very much traceable. Okay.
You can send bitcoin by literally only
pointing that transaction back to a
previous transaction in the chain
of blocks, right? A block chain.
That's the only way. And
that. And so your transaction,
when you make one in the bitcoin network
points back to every transaction that
came before it all the way back
to the coin base transaction,
the coin base transaction
is that transaction that
occurs when a minor and only
a minor can make a coin base transaction
received a reward from mining some
blocks. So it's like bitcoin
that comes from nothing,
but I mean it comes as reward for
performing the proof of work algorithm,
but right,
so you can trace any transaction back
all the way to the coin base transaction
and the bitcoin network.
And you might be saying,
well how am I able to to to do this?
Well,
it turns out that you can look up any
transaction in the blockchain explorer.
So that's that. And this can be
hard to do manually, right? I mean,
you say you send,
send a transaction to somebody else
and then they send it to somebody else,
right?
That's two links in the chain.
It's easy to just go click once and
then click once again on the blockchain
explorer.
But as nodes you're adding the complexity
increases exponentially, right?
Because as those funds are split and
then those funds are split and then those
ones are splits,
it gets harder and harder and harder to
tell where that transaction originated
from. And if you don't believe me
when I say that Bitcoin is traceable,
just ask the founder of Silk Road,
the online dark web market
for selling illegal items.
There are people literally sitting in
jail right now because bitcoin is in fact
a very, very traceable
system. Okay. So Silk Road,
I mean there's this whole
story on about Silk Road.
They should definitely
make a movie about it.
I'm the guy was ordering hits on people
and he was doing all this crazy stuff,
which I don't condone and I
don't think it's cool. Uh,
but he's sitting in jail right now and
they probably will and they probably have
made a movie about it. But, um, my point
is that bitcoin is traceable, right?
Um,
so yes,
criminals don't want to use a currency
that is traceable. Um, but if,
but the thing is whether
or not I make this video,
criminals will find a fine
an untraceable currency.
You just have to type into
Google untraceable currency.
If you want to do bad,
you will do bad, right? I am not
making this video for criminals.
I'm making this video for
you. You are my viewer, right?
I'm making this video for people who
want to understand all the technical
details of how cryptocurrencies work and
then use this knowledge to then do good
for the world, right? This
is just knowledge in your
arsenal to do good. Okay?
So just remember that as a
motivation behind this video.
So you could attempt to make anonymous
transactions in bitcoin three ways.
So remember, bitcoin is not
anonymous. It's pseudonymous.
Meaning even if someone traces back
the trail of transactions back to you,
that is still your public address,
that public address says
nothing about your identity.
It's not like the word Saroj is
embedded in my public address, right?
So how can you tell ownership? Well,
there's a variety of ways, Ip addresses,
you know, um, finding the end
points of, I'll talk about
it. Let me, let me, let me,
let me show you this. So there are three
ways to attempt anonymous transactions.
The first way is to create a new wallet
after every transaction and coinbase.com
does this and does this like by default.
Um,
but as soon as that money is used,
that end point person could be
squeezed for information, right?
So if you send some money to somebody
and you want to remain anonymous,
you're creating wallets
between every transaction.
Eventually someone is going to use that
money in the real world for, you know,
paying a dentist or buying
a soccer ball or whatever.
And then that is an end point to
person, a real person that, you know,
people with guns or
whatever, it can say, hey,
give me the information and then
they can trace it back to you.
Another way is to wash your money through
a tumbler and a tumbler is a service
that aggregates your money with many
other funds and then sweeps them through
large financial institutions.
So if I send money to a tumbler service,
other people send money
to that Tumbler service,
those funds are then aggregated together
and then split up into little amounts
and then they're sent out through,
through these different gateways. Right?
So it's very hard to tell who
originated a transaction. However,
in a court of law,
this could be deemed as
supporting evidence for
criminal intent by courts. Um,
you could also wash your money,
wash your money by purchasing assets,
real world assets, you know,
um, a basketball court,
a house,
a car,
and then transferring that money back
to bitcoin or another currency and just
doing that over and over again. Um,
but that is illegal. And uh, yeah,
so these are all not good methods.
There possible methods,
but they're mostly illegal
and you will get caught. Okay.
So again, is it on traceability
only? Good for criminals? No,
no. It is good for criminals. Yes.
So with paypal in the early days,
so it was bitcoin in the early days.
Uh, but there are legitimate use cases,
um, for non criminals like us, right?
So distributed online
payment vulnerability is an
example. So a target, right?
Target the corporation or you know,
any of these corporations,
they mind your transaction data to
then use it for predictive analytics to
predict what you're going to purchase
and show you ads and other things to make
you purchase things. This is
your data. It's very valuable.
And as everything gets automated,
your data will be the only agency
you have in this new world.
It will be the only value of that you
own, right? So you should be paid for it,
right? And so if you understand
where this is all going,
you'll see that data is the most
valuable asset we have, right?
So watch my decentralized
application video,
just search decentralized
applications to Raj,
and you'll understand more about what I
mean when I say just how valuable your
data is. But the point is that if
your transaction history is anonymous,
then uh, they have to ask you for it,
which means they have to pay you for it.
And as you're getting these payments
from all these different institutions for
your data, you're making something like a
basic income, right? Just from your data.
And that's where we're headed.
And that's the reason we'd want to use
an anonymous currency like Monero for
example, right? So of user
visits and online shop.
The online shop collects user data and
then an algorithm predicts purchase
probability. You should be paid
for this in short. So let's,
let's get into the technical details
now, shall we? So the Crypto,
no protocol introduced the idea of
anonymous, not synonymous transactions.
So it all started with bitcoin.
So by coin was the first implementation
of an anonymous, uh, currency, right?
It was,
this is the first implementation of the
crypto note protocol is this white paper.
And then there were some
offshoots of bite coin, right?
So First Buddha coin and then pallet
in coin, Bull Berry, and then Monroe.
And then Minero was the one
that really took off, right?
Minero I think is number 10 right
now on coin market cap.com. It's a,
I think $7 billion market cap.
So it's a lot of money.
And all of these currencies that
follows were offshoots of Minero.
They were forks up narrow
with added features.
But monero is really the most stable
and the most popular of the anonymous
currencies out there. Okay. So, um,
crypto transactions cannot be followed
through the blockchain in a way that
reveals who sent or received addresses.
So Minero is a virgin of crypto
note that hides the sender,
the amount that transaction
broadcast and the receiver.
So the sender is made anonymous
through the use of what are called ring
signatures,
which I'll explain the amount through
ring confidential transactions that
brought the transaction broadcasts,
like the location of where you are,
your IP address,
et Cetera,
through an ITP router called calvary and
the receiver through the use of stealth
addresses. Now I'm going to explain how
all four of these things work. Okay,
so let's get, let's get into this,
right? So Monroe has a lot of features.
The two main ones that really matter,
that make it unique are and
traceability and, and on.
Linkability means if I have a public
address in the narrow network,
no transaction can be linked
back to that public address.
So anyone can take my public
address and they can say, well,
what transactions were sent to and
from this address and no one will know.
Untraceable means that no one can tell
where any transaction originated from.
So they're, they're two
separate of descriptions there.
They're very similar but not quite,
and I'll talk about each right now.
So for an linkability,
right? So for unlikeability,
here's how bitcoin works in Bitcoin.
Everyone has a public address,
25 character public address,
and you use it to receive funds and anyone
can see how much you received, right?
Because it's a public ledger.
When sending funds,
you announced to the entire
bitcoin network that the
funds you own now belong to
the recipients public address.
So that transaction is fully public.
The difference in Minero is
this. So this is an image of, of,
of very high level image of Helmand.
Arrow works.
And I'll get into the details in a second.
So in Minero,
everyone has a public address like this,
right?
So it's a much longer public
address. Um, hold on. And,
uh,
unlike Bitcoin, your funds are not
associated with your public address.
So when you send funds to
someone else's public address,
you're actually sending those funds to
a randomly created one time destination
address right here.
The commitment public key.
So no public record of sending
or receiving funds. When
I send funds to someone,
they're actually sent
to a onetime address.
It's just created temporarily
just for that transaction.
And that's what's public, not my
public key. Not that, not the scent,
not the receivers, public key,
but that commitment publicly.
And so that public
address will never appear.
So your public address will never appear
in the public record of transactions.
Instead,
a stealth address is recorded in a way
that only you and the recipient can
recognize the incoming funds.
So when the recipient checks for funds,
they need to scan the blockchain to see
if any transactions are destined for
them.
So the recipient has a secret beauty,
which is used to check each transaction
when they scanned the blockchain to see
if it was addressed to them.
And because the recipient is the only
one that knows the secret view key,
only the recipients can see the funds
that have been sent to them. Right.
So that's why when you
launch Minero wallet,
it's scanning the blockchain to see
if any transactions have occurred, um,
for you as a recipient. Right? So,
but anyone who has your secret view
key can also see what funds you have
received, right? So when you send a
transaction, right? So it's an input,
the output is going to be this
commitment, public key, which is public.
And then these two secret view keys,
one for the sender.
So I can see how much I sent and one for
the receivers so they can see how much
they received. But publicly speaking,
there's just this one time address,
not linked to either you or the center.
Okay.
And so that's the idea
of stealth addresses.
And what that does is it
hides the receiver. Okay?
Right? So, um, it's also untraceable.
So we talked about an linkability,
but it's also untraceable. Well, let
me talk about an traceability. Okay.
So for an traceability, that's where the
use of ring signatures come into play,
right? So for ring signatures in Bitcoin,
when you, when you have an input,
so some incoming transaction,
right?
It uses its signed using a
signature by some identity, right?
And then all inputs are clearly linked
to a previous transaction, right?
So anyone can view this input and say,
oh, that's where it originated from.
But in Minero when you,
when you receive an input,
it's not just one input
that you're receiving it.
There's several and they're
all linked together.
So as a ring and all of these us,
all of these inputs are signed using,
uh, using what's called a ring signature.
And then any input is going to be linked
to more than one previous transaction.
So no one will be able to tell who that
input originated from because it's a
part of a ring of transactions. Let
me go into what I mean. Okay. Okay.
So here's what I mean by ring signatures.
So the Minero money supply is
divided into outputs. Just like a,
the u s dollar is divided in $2
bills, quarters, dimes, pennies.
Monero is divided into outputs,
divisions of currency.
And these outputs store a certain value
of Minero each and the value they hold
can change over time.
So suppose that these are all the outputs
that exist and the one you control and
can spend is highlighted in red.
So let's say these are all the outputs,
all the green ones. And I own
this red one. Number Eight,
which let's say is the equivalent of life,
let's say $300 and some
of these are like 200.
Some of these are $10 in Minero
currency, right? And, uh,
when I create a Monero transaction,
I'm using a ring signature to hide
which input is actually being spent. So,
and the way this has done is
by making it seem like as,
as if all the chosen inputs
are the possible real center.
So when I send an input,
when I send a transaction,
there are five other transactions that
are picked by random from other nodes in
the network, and we don't need
their permission to choose those.
They're just there to obfuscate where
that transaction is coming from, right?
They're all linked together in a ring
and they're all signed using a ring
signature.
So it's so,
so in the photo you're real input is red
and the five selected inputs are light
blue and these inputs can be
controlled by anyone else.
We don't need their permission to add
their input to the rings signature.
We signed them all such that an outside
observer can not determine which is the
real one being spent.
Right?
And so once we have
selected the other inputs,
we need to finish creating
the ring CT ring signature.
So the ring CT ring signature is used
to hide the amount that is spent.
The rinks signature hides that the sender,
the stealth address highs,
the receiver and the ring
CT spring signature hides,
the amount of that is being sent.
So you sign it in such a way that all
these inputs appear to be the real one
used. And this signature includes
several other important elements.
So this is a more detailed view of what
a transaction looks like in the narrow
network, right? So when
I make a transaction,
there are up to six other transactions
that are added to the, to the ring, right?
All these rings, rings are signed using
a ring signature rights. And importantly,
very critically, a key image is
created from all of these transactions.
That key image is one hash and it's
given to the network as proof that the
signature was created appropriately.
The network verifies that this image has
not been used before to prevent double
spending.
So it's got to list in the blockchain
of all of these key images and they'll
look for match has this key image
being sent before? Yes. Okay.
It's double spending. You can't do it.
No, this is a valid transaction. Go ahead.
And so that's how a double spending
is presented using the, the key image.
Next is the Peterson commitment.
So this is used to prevent other people
from knowing how much is actually being
spent. So it's a formula, right?
So you have the actual
amount that is spent a,
it's multiplied by a random number and
this constant value here and the result
is this number that is a result of the
formula. And that that is a commitment,
right?
You can use this commitment to commit to
spending a certain value that only you
have the authority to spend,
but other people don't know what
that value is because it's, it's, um,
the result of this formula, right? It's
not the, it's not the original amount.
It's a result of this formula. And
that's what the public, right? So,
um, so the Peterson commitment
is a critical component
of the ring confidential
transaction or ring CT hides the actual
value by adding a random number x.
The commission value is calculated for
the set of inputs and outputs in the
transaction and it is
broadcast to the network.
So that's what the network
sees is the result of that,
of that Peterson
commitment formula and it,
and so that all comes together to
form the ring. Ct rings a country,
and the result is an unknown amount of
Monroe being spent. That commitment.
Public key is what's used by the network
to verify that commitment that I talked
about before. Right? So how do
the outputs get used over time?
So we can compare a bitcoin Emma
narrow to find out, right? So,
and this theoretical history of the
outputs, we control all the blogs.
Highlighted reds are the ones
where the output appears.
And if this was for Bitcoin, we would
eat really easily be able to tell.
But this output was transferred from
user a to B to c. But with narrow,
it's not so simple. There
are three reasons for an
output to show up in a block.
Either it's new money and
a coin base transaction.
It was actually spent or it was added
as a decoy and a ring signature.
I also want to talk about covert,
right?
So we talked about how the sender
is hidden using ring signatures.
We talked about how the amount
is hidden using ring CT.
We talked about how the receiver
is hidden using stealth addresses,
but how about the uh, location,
right? Like where you are,
your Ip addressed and that's um,
office skated using this ITP
routing service called covert.
It's kind of like tour,
but basically your transaction is routed
through all these different nodes,
these Internet, um, uh,
what do they call these internet
invisible Internet project nodes, right?
I ITP nodes and these nodes,
pasture messages along and have no
visibility over what is in them.
And that's under construction right now.
It's getting better and better over time.
And you can view its progress on get hub.
It's all public and open source,
but it's double spending proof,
right? Because we talked about that,
that key image that the whole blockchain
has a copy of and it's blockchain
analysis resistant. Not
Completely, nothing is,
but it's the most blockchain analysis
resistance cryptocurrency that exists
currently. And uh, yeah, so
this is a huge high level,
high level overview of
everything I've talked about.
If you want to go into more details,
really look into this. But uh, yeah,
those four components are really the
key features of, of Monero. Lastly,
adaptive parameters, like we said
before on the narrow transaction,
has an ambiguous output origin,
an unknown amount in a commitment
and an unknown receiver.
So for every transaction on the network,
all of the information stored on
the blockchain is obfuscated, right?
So let's talk about how to,
lastly,
I want to talk about how to buy him an
Arrow and then how to mine Minero. Okay.
In terms of how to buy Minero,
I've got this great link here.
It's in the Jupiter notebook in the
get hub description to check it out.
But Change Lee is the best
site I found two by Minero.
You can buy it using visa or
mastercard. Um, there's a,
you can buy with bitcoin and you can
buy it with even us dollar if you so
pleased or doge or all of
these currencies. So definitely
check out this website,
change Lee and um,
to mind Minero I found
this a really great, uh,
python repository that
you can clone in docker.
It's got the all the docker
dependencies ready for Mac and Linux.
You can run it and you can start
mining it as well. And a, yeah,
it's going to be awesome.
But yeah,
it wraps this javascript
mining library for coin hive.
That's kind of like this generic mining
library for a bunch of cryptocurrencies,
but it works with any Minero pool.
So these are pools of miners based
on the stratum mining protocol.
You can set up your own pool. There's
no depth feet, there's no ad block,
and you can use any pool you'd like,
but you clone this repository repository,
you CD into it, you build it with
Docker, and then you run it with docker.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos. And for now, I've got a plan,
my scaling strategy for the New Year.
So thanks for watching.